usually people are really confused when
I tell them what I do I'd tell them like
yeah I want to fingerboard company like
those tech tax used to get in some like
yeah but professional
skateboarding makes me feel awesome it
doesn't get boring it's always a
challenge there's no rules
fingerboarding a skateboarding both have
that
you
I started fingerboarding in 4th grade I
had a lot of fun playing with the tech
decks and then I wanted to kind of
improve them a lot of times the screws
would come out so I'd glue them in and
just start modifying things like that
and I just realized I could make them
better and better a lot of kids wanted
to buy them so I kind of put a name on
it and it grew into this huge business
over time there's hundreds of thousands
of people out there that are into this
we are at the flat-faced rendezvous
location in Dracut Massachusetts and
it's pretty much a big building filled
with fingerboard parks and I do huge
events here where kids fly in from all
over the place to come and fingerboard
together when you go into a contest
that's crazy because there's stadium
seating and there's everyone looking at
you and lighting and cameras my first
few contests I got crazy adrenaline rush
like you don't even remember the thing
after you do your run I don't do any
warm-ups or exercises with my hands for
fingerboarding apparently some people do
calisthenics the rules are pretty much
you want to use two fingers you'll have
maybe thirty seconds or a minute or so
and you just do a run and there will be
a whole bunch of judges they'll judge
you on consistency style the tricks you
do it's like really high pressure
you can't even really put it into words
it's a crazy kind of feeling and
atmosphere when so many people get
together from all over the world all
over the country and some of them it's
like a really really big deal to them
like that's the only thing they want to
do all year it just makes me super happy
because I can barely believe that I'm
the reason they're there like because of
something that I set up and that I'm
doing bicycle kicks spikes and flips all
up a giant trampoline while the referee
plays music this is possible a sport
with Spanish origins it has gained a big
following with the youth in Colombia
Paseo listen I discipline a kemi's claw
football volleyball team nasiha yah
party tray una discipline artistic akela
music oh hey hombre preju llama - Lana
Balan Kiara same music oh oh SEL de que
para synchronizer el deporte con la
musica like a tener Sookie - oregano
para entender SAE porky suerte prophase
Oh
minami Leonardo Rey Mira Limbo's our
laser forma or yoga or desta discipline
naka muka table I own program axiom
Aquarian top or Quentin este momento la
idea esto es Cree our valor en los
chicos or medio del deporte Lopez okay
ah bless una disciplina que tiene comme
un objetivo principal Darla's una
splasheo yeah Lucy COEs para que pueden
mostrar towaway Mahina concatenate in
Bogota the government has funded a
possible program for at-risk youth to
teach them the game and keep them off
the streets and away from violence la
ciotat soon as un poco in Segura ya que
tammini Co victim IIST antes Rose Casey
no contest oh and si vamos al ghul NC
a-- entonces todo ese contests owe me a
ah trabajo no Chico's decirles Piske a
yatra forma de vere me meta como forma
or es dar la los chicos UNS pacion de yo
se pone do a tear yo yo creo que no ina
amateur Gretchen vast antes cosas en un
de port a kata Jamil attention Sosa
steady solution are con el deporte el
deporte lo motiva you know como hacer
mejor persona yo a conversa bowls a
Presta para
when I perform on stage I'm in my own
world the only thing going through my
head is that nothing else exists but the
trick I'm doing in that current moment
the yo-yo flings up in the air goes
under my leg it's being bounced back and
forth between the strings with being
sideways horizontally the way I express
myself on stage comes out and I love
that feeling where you could kind of be
free Boop
when I'm not on stage I'm a graphic
designer
living in Los Angeles most of the year
I'm just like any typical recent grad
trying to figure out what to do with
their life but come summer I'm preparing
to be the best yo-yo performer at the
world yo-yo contest my name is Ben Conde
I am a professional yo-yo player and I'm
ranked number one in North America in
the offstring division I think people
think yo-yos are incredibly simple but
it's gone a long way since being a toy
that goes up and down and now there's
all these new elements to it many people
don't know there are five styles of
yo-yo there's one handed yo-yo there's
two handed responsive yo-yo two handed
unresponsive yo-yo counterweight Helio
and off string yo-yo which is what I
specialize in it's riskier it's the
riskiest division in my opinion because
of the fact that it can fall off the
string for the past 19 years I've been
working on yo-yo tricks trying to figure
out what tricks to do that's half the
battle because you're performing those
tricks to music one of the hardest parts
is telling a story through your music
giving the right energy and work on
making something flow it's a lot of hard
work that you put into it and any split
second of losing focus it seems like a
whole years of work goes the weight I
have to prove that I'm not going to
waste audience's time and for people to
respond positively towards it
that I like can't thank the sport no I
started playing yo-yo when I was four
years old and it's something I care
about it's not something I do for money
like it's a toy it's a toy at simplest
form and I just happen to be competing
with it for a really long time and
spending a lot of time learning in the
end it's something that makes me feel
comfortable
it keeps me youthful it reminds me of
what I would be playing with as a kid
when I'm juggling I feel like I have a
superpower to me it's just an amazing
feeling to keep lots of things in the
air and to keep these big patterns going
Sam Malcolm is a combat juggler the
object of the sport is to keep all three
pins in the air while preventing your
opponent from doing likewise light
bumping and arm-to-arm altercations are
permitted the last juggler standing wins
I got into combat juggling at about 3
a.m. at a juggling convention
flying around with some friends just
trying to see who could be the last one
standing we've all been to circuses
we've all seen variety acts but this is
something that makes it more of a sport
if you're playing football you have to
put in the work to get good at football
juggling is no different you have to put
in hours and hours and hours of practice
you're not only accounting for the three
objects that you're juggling you have to
anticipate that there could be something
flying at your head from fifty feet in
the air because it's so well and crazy
there's so many other people playing I
warm up for combat juggling I jump rope
for about ten minutes I work on
balancing things when my head and on my
face there's a lot of wild throws
there's a lot of wild saves there's a
lot of jumping around and falling and
running on the ground and I try to go
through all of those things to get ready
you see incredible plays by people like
Steph Curry or LeBron James I can look
at those people and tell you like they'd
be great jugglers because I have that
awareness over their body
it's something new and exciting and
fresh something fun it's something
different so I'm optimistic that it'll
grow and become something really great
it's punching it's kicking armored
combat is sort of like MMA but with
weapons to me this is the ultimate
combat sport my name is Andres Inoue I'm
the co-founder of the armored combat
league I'm the captain of the national
sword fighting team the USA Knights our
form of armored combat started a little
over four years ago it came to our ears
that there were some people over in
Europe that were doing this and we had
to build the United States team and
trying to be competitive for the world
most of the arms and armor that we use
comes from the late 14th in early 15th
century Western Europe now there's some
other armors but the best bang for the
buck is usually late 14th century or
early 15th century armor it's kind of
counterintuitive but if you're wearing
decent armor and you get hit with a
sword half the time you don't even know
you've been hit if you play football
you've done a rougher thing
it's a brawl I mean there's no doubt
about it you're going out there and
you're brawling just like in rugby or a
football you've got to have a plan when
you go out there the flankers end up
with three people on them and you end up
with two now melees are a lot more
intense those rules are you fight until
submission or until you put somebody
down to the ground there's no typical
person for armoured combat you've got
people from all walks of life whether
it's some sort of martial arts or
football or rugby there's some history
buffs too and they'll fight and fight
and fight and they'll give everything to
the point of exhaustion that's what
makes a winner it's all here these guys
will go hard at each other they're going
to be swinging as hard as they can
they're trying to knock you down they're
trying to get you to submit and then
they're going to help you up they're
going to pat you on the back and there
you'll have a steak and a beer with you